hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer friesen TV and
today we're streaming live from reason
studio in Los Angeles today we're
talking with Lisa Snell director of
education and child welfare studies at
Reason Foundation a nonprofit that
publishes Reason magazine reason calm
and reason TV Lisa writes and speaks
regularly about education policy it is
perhaps best known for spearheading the
campaign against universal preschool in
California which voters rejected
overwhelmingly in a ballot initiative in
2006 Lisa made the point that forcing
all four year olds to attend
state-supported preschool was incredibly
weak from an educational perspective and
potentially devastating from a cost
perspective Lisa holds a master's degree
in communication from Cal State and is
the mother of two children education is
something she not only take seriously
but personally Lisa thanks for talking
to us thanks so much so give me the
elevator pitch for a school choice why
why is it so important for students and
their parents to be able to choose among
competing k through 12 educational
options and what's wrong with
traditional publicly funded education
based on residents so in our life we
take for granted choice in all aspects
that are so much less important than the
education of our own children so whether
you know it's which cell phone you
choose or which airline you fly on or
even where you buy your school supplies
we think nothing about making choices
and even in the arena of education we
would never think about putting our
two-year-old in a school based on where
we live because it's so critical for
them to be safe and then once you get
out of k-12 education in higher
education it would be ridiculous to
assign people colleges based on their
residential assignment so we really have
this kind of weird artifact fact left
over from school finance and how
districts grew up where for this K
through 12 5 through 17 or 18 we're
going to assign schools based on
residential assignment and you won't
have a choice in that but I think that's
really changing we just got done with
national school choice week where there
was 3,600 events so
the country celebrating school choice
and the school choice movement is really
growing with lots of really cool options
yeah and can you map out a few more of
the details of what the school choice
landscape looks like today I mean how
many kids are in choice schools and what
what forms are these schools taking
right so I mean I think within
traditional school districts and in
charter schools in private school choice
programs there's been a huge change in
attitude about the expectation that
you'll have more say over where your
kids go to school and we actually now
have 6,000 charter schools and basically
what a charter school is is it's a
school that started by you know an
individual group of people whether it's
a non-profit and they have a contract
with the school district or the state or
some governing body where they can run
their school but the big difference is
they're open enrollment schools so the
kids they don't get funded if the kids
don't show up and they also have a lot
of autonomy from the regular rules and
restrictions that regular traditional
district schools live under so in some
communities we have a huge amount of
market share here in Los Angeles the LA
Unified School District has lost close
to 200,000 kids in the last five years
to charter schools and in fact just this
last year in 2012 they had for more than
40 of their traditional public schools
actually chose to convert to charter
schools in Los Angeles and they had to
get fifty percent of their teachers to
agree to become a charter school in
order to do that and then private school
choice has really taken off as well it
used to be that Cleveland and Milwaukee
were the only two places you could find
school vouchers in the United States and
now we have about 39 school choice
programs that are either school voucher
tax credit or education savings accounts
and so we have the first examples where
statewide programs for school vouchers
and actually Indiana has a large school
voucher program that impacts almost
every kid in the state and more recently
Governor Jindal in Louisiana has
actually developed a statewide voucher
program
and going going back to LA I mean since
we're in a like it could you put the
200,000 number in perspective I mean
what kind of percentage is that right so
it's probably around twenty percent of
LA students at this point and so Los
Angeles Unified has always been the
second largest school district after New
York in the country and so for years
they had between 800 thousand and nine
hundred thousand kids and so they're
down closer to six hundred thousand
students now and obviously some of that
is demographic change but the largest
explanation for why so many kids have
left the school district is there's now
about a hundred and fifty charter
schools that have grown up around la
unified and so they had this huge
building program in Los Angeles where
they've spent almost twenty billion
dollars the largest public works
construction program actually in the
country and they argued that they were
overcrowded and at capacity and so what
you see now is they've actually built
all of these new schools and LA Unified
has all these schools that are under
capacity because of the competition from
charter schools great and I mean what
are some of the other big trends in
school choice it I know one of your
mantras is let the money follow the
child and which of these have been
successful and which of them have been
not so successful right I mean I think
the interesting thing is that there is a
change and starting to think about the
price of a student and the cost instead
of just you know having districts get
per pupil funding and they spend money
on staffing and it's completely
disconnected from the student because of
charter schools and these voucher
programs people have been much more
familiar the way that we fund higher
education whether it's a Pell Grant or a
student loan you know they get paid
based on a student enrolling who pays
tuition and private schools get tuition
based on the kids that enroll but in the
public space it's really been a
disconnect between the money and the
kids and so I think that's really
starting to change is that we're
starting to think about and especially
because of the digital revolution
moving into so an interesting program in
Louisiana is called course choice and so
Governor Jindal New Orleans has almost
eighty percent of kids or higher in
charter schools and then they have a
statewide voucher program where kids can
go to private schools or public schools
and so the governor the next thing that
he decided to do was to go one step
further where not only will we have a
voucher attached to kids but we should
be able to have multiple providers so if
you want to take a physics course from
this provider and you want to do
physical education at karate class and
you know that you should actually be
able to fund the student down to the
incremental level of the course choice
not just one voucher that would go to
one provider so we're actually starting
to see trends in Arizona has a similar
program called education savings
accounts where the parents actually
don't have to take a private a voucher
to one school they would actually get
the value of the per pupil dollars and
then they would put that in a savings
account similar to like a medical
savings account and then they could use
that money for any kind of educational
services that they wanted to get for
their kid so you know if they needed a
speech therapist or they wanted to have
you know some kind of special science
camp that they sent their kid to all in
adapting sounds it sounds expensive but
in reality it would be driving costs
down as a whole right right so it's
interesting i was talking the other day
to the sky from the broad foundation who
does a lot of investment in education
and he was talking about New Jersey in
Newark right the kids are funded at
twenty-seven thousand dollars a kid per
year and if you just didn't have those
kids go to school and you put that
twenty seven thousand dollars into an
investment account every year and let it
compound when they were eighteen they
would be set for life financially I mean
we are already spending like a huge huge
amount of money on these kids and we
can't see what the value is that we get
for that money and you brought up
Louisiana and New Orleans and yeah they
have they do have a lot of programs and
they've gotten praise but they've also
gotten criticism so can you talk
about this and whether it can and still
would be a good model for other parts of
the country to replicate right so if we
start with describing what's happened in
New Orleans after Hurricane Katrina
basically the public school system was
wiped out and the traditional schools
were disbanded and the unions the
contract was null and void and so they
really had a chance to have a fresh
start and so in New Orleans almost a
hundred percent of the kids will be
going they all go to choice space
schools and eighty percent of them are
independent operators that have schools
and so in the last five years New
Orleans has seen a tremendous amount of
growth in student achievement graduation
rates parental satisfaction and that's
the thing is there's both quantitative
and qualitative measures that we care
about I mean obviously we want to know
that we're getting some kind of basic
performance in terms of student
achievement for the money we're spending
but then the other thing is is that
because of the tragedy of the Commons so
many public schools don't even do
fundamental things like clean bathrooms
you know food that's edible safety for
the children and you know it's harder to
quantify those things in places like New
Orleans but that's one of the big
indicators is the parents are happy and
satisfied because the kids are in clean
you know positive environments where
they're safe and you know so the critics
you know say the best that they can do
is say oh these claims are exaggerated
things aren't as good as they say they
are but clearly on multiple indicators
everything has moved in a positive
direction and the other thing is other
districts so Jefferson Parish which is
close by New Orleans has actually
started copying and opening up their
lower performing schools to charter
schools and they implemented a money
follow the child's school finance system
so you know I think there's a new book
out by this guy called Andy smack where
he basically makes the argument that the
school district should be disbanded and
that we should have contractual
relationships with individual schools or
groups of schools and that that's really
where
are moving because we can hold them
accountable when we do that great and
for the actual curricula is education
how education is being taught are being
changed with the charter schools and
other forms of choice schools or is it
just moving the kids to a better
facility and taking conventional
education and just improving it right so
I mean it's both at the one hand there's
a lot of change kind of just at the
margins where you know in a lot of cases
these schools are traditional college
prep you know they say that their
mission is to make kids more prepared
for college and they still are teaching
you know the same curriculum the same
kind of standardized you know it's not
that the schools look revolutionary but
they do things so much better in that
there's more communication between the
teachers it may be something as simple
as changing the scheduling so that a
math and science teacher only has
instead of having five groups of 25
different kids you know they have a
class of 30 kids for math and science
and 30 kids for math and science and
they stay with those kids through the
day I mean the problem is that education
is so centralized and even simple tweaks
on the margin you can't do in a school
district so on the one hand charter
schools just have a lot of freedom to do
kind of common-sense changes that we
would all expect and to really monitor
their performance and so their
relationships with teachers are much
different so in most districts teachers
are assigned schools in the same way
that kids are assigned to schools you
know it's based on seniority or where
there's a need and there's not you know
the principal may not have even the
chance to interview the teacher to see
if they're a good fit for the school so
on the front end it's kind of a mutual
relationship where i'm a teacher and you
interview me and i want to work at your
school and we're all on the same team to
make this school better and so there is
kind of a different personnel
relationship and an ownership of the
outcomes for the kids because everyone
is there through voluntary
and that's a positive thing and so I
think that explains a lot of the
difference right there and then the
other thing is you are starting to see
more and more experimentation in charter
schools where they actually do say okay
I want to have a niche curriculum where
I'm going to have you know a tag-along
immersion school where kids you know
learn to all of their lessons in two
different languages and if that works
for the kids and the parents that's
great or we're going to focus on stem
and math and science and technology and
that's going to be the focus of our
school and you know I think one of the
things that's different is that they can
spend so much more time experimenting
and measuring the results without having
to spend so much time being accountable
for paperwork and I know that charter
schools do boast better results but i'm
wondering i mean critics might think
that because charter schools are taking
skimming the top of the class anyway
what's saying that it's not just those
kids who would be doing better anyway
and what happens to the kids who are
left behind time so i mean there's been
a lot of focus on the demographics of
charter schools and a large number of
these high-performing charter schools so
for example here in los angeles they
have the exact same demographics as the
traditional public schools because most
charter schools are oversubscribed and
that means they have waiting lists and
so that means they truly have random
assignment when it comes to who gets
into their charter school because they
have to hold lotteries and lots of kids
don't get in but they're the same large
population of kids that want to go to
that school and so I'm not saying that
there's never been a case of a charter
school skimming obviously I'm sure there
has been but in general these charter
schools that are high performing are
serving a very similar population and in
many cases they serve kids that have
been ill served by the traditional
public schools and they actually may be
at an even lower quartile in terms of
reading and math achievement and things
like that when they start out in the
charter school because they've left the
traditional public school because they
aren't learning
these kind of basic student achievement
areas so take eva moskowitz is a very
outspoken charter school proponent in
new york and she has a group of schools
called Success Academy and one of the
interesting features about her school is
they actually share a traditional public
school with a group of kids that go to
the traditional public school and the
kids in the charter school are far
outscoring the kids in the same
classrooms in the same buildings in the
traditional public school and would you
think that those teachers or
administrators would ever like walk
across the hall your geez you're getting
20 points higher is there something that
you're doing different than us and
that's the thing as education they're so
siloed and unwilling to learn from some
of these best practices that these other
schools you doing that is is it is it
teachers unions I mean I think that the
only way that you can incentivize people
to improve their behavior is if there is
some kind of change when they do badly
so you know if I don't do my job I lose
my job but in most traditional public
schools so take Los Angeles again for an
example a school that's out forty
percent capacity now because most of
their student body has gone to a charter
school or another choice in Los Angeles
still has a fully funded teachers
curriculum facility and they've seen
really no change on the ground because
they've lost so many kids or because
they're low scoring so until the money
actually follows the child and you
actually and so a bunch of urban
districts have tried this now so let's
take Baltimore for example because I
think it's a really compelling example
you know Baltimore was made famous for
having terrible schools because of the
wire right season four really
highlighted you know and kids weren't
going to class doing drugs crime
whatever and so Baltimore five years ago
got a new superintendent that insisted
that as part of his contract he would
have autonomy to do what he wanted and
one of the things he did is he has been
very open to charters
schools coming into Baltimore and
running low performing schools but then
the other thing that he did is he said
every school will be a school of choice
and the money within the district will
follow the child and schools that have
low performance and low enrollment will
be closed and so he actually looked at
the data and a lot of schools got closed
they turned over forty percent of the
principles that could not manage their
budgets and so Baltimore today has on
almost every indicator higher test
scores higher graduation rates but some
of the most compelling data out of
Baltimore is actually not traditional
school performance but data that affects
the community and that is that
incarceration for high school students
has fallen by sixty percent murder and
homicide rates has fallen by seventy two
percent for disadvantaged kids that go
to those urban city schools in Baltimore
so in some ways if you were writing the
script for the wire today many of the
things that used to happen to those kids
in terms of outcomes and the primary
reason for that is you know there are a
lot of teachers that are working hard
there's a lot of principles that are
working hard but if those high schools
don't keep those kids interested in
school and if they just let them leave
they don't get the money and that's the
fundamental thing that has changed in
Baltimore is if the kids aren't there
and the teachers aren't there there's no
money for that individual school and
let's talk about race and class a little
bit more I mean you brought up
demographics in student bodies but what
about i mean the proponents of school
choice are mainly upper-class
republicans and working class blacks and
you don't usually see these groups you
know in the same room working together
so i mean it's interesting i think more
and more we are seeing a lot of kind of
bipartisan support so the Brookings
Institute right which is a very kind of
progressive kind of traditional liberal
think tank they actually now have
started what they call a choice and
competition index and they actually rank
every traditional school district in the
United States on how much choice and
competition that they have and for them
to take such an investment and that kind
of an initiative and so Louisiana New
Orleans actually ranks number one and
surprisingly New York City ranks second
and they look at things like how many
alternatives exist does the funding
follow the child is there information
for the parents to make a correct choice
but so when you have groups like the
Brookings Institute that have made one
of their fundamental education
initiatives measuring choice and
competition you can see how far we've
come and so the Los Angeles school
choice event that just happened here on
febuary on January 25th they actually
had a group of charter schools and
speakers with a lot of kids and Gloria
Romero who used to be a state center
here in Los Angeles and is a you know
classic Democrat she actually runs up
Democrats for education reform and you
know you see more and more people that
are substantial leaders in the
Democratic Party so whether it's cory
booker or someone like Gloria Romero
they're coming out for school choice as
a civil rights issue and then I think
that's kind of strange bedfellows or a
strange coalition with kind of the more
people that have always made arguments
for choice from kind of an economic
perspective or a market people deserve
choice versus the civil rights issue and
you see these groups working together in
positive ways to get bills passed so for
instance Florida which has been a hotbed
of school choice you know Jeb Bush was
able to work with the black Democratic
caucus to get school choice passed in
that state and so you really see that
happening more and more across the
country is it is these coalition's from
both sides of the aisle now does that
mean that there's not a position from
the status quo or the unions or the
establishment they still spend a lot of
money to oppose these things but more
and more people are speaking out and the
other thing is we have a lot of examples
now like Louisiana or like new york city
of you know the world doesn't come to an
end when we have school choice right and
opponents on other side might say school
choices and going far enough we want
complete separation between schools and
state we shouldn't have public schools
at all so we really have a continuum of
school choice you know if you think
about the ultimate market in education
parents would take full responsibility
either through homeschooling or private
paying for education and then on this
end we have traditionally funded
ninety-nine percent of the money goes to
public schools and it's all based on
taxpayer money and so in between that we
have a lot of steps on how close we are
to a true free market and people get
pretty upset about where they come down
on that continuum you know people who
like tax credits they like them better
than vouchers because when you get to
keep your own money you have less
government entanglement but we're still
at a place where we just are starting to
make inroads into competition at the
margins and the fact is we have a single
provider and a single payer system and
so in my view and I think in this kind
of bigger tent approach anything that
moves us along to breaking up that
education monopoly where the money
follows the child is an improvement and
I can understand the risk that we don't
want private schools to become heavily
regulated you know we don't want choices
to be diminished because private
enterprise starts mimicking government
schools and I think while that is
something we have to be vigilant about
and is a real caution if you look at
purely private schools today that take
no government money they're still
regulated in many many ways by the
government whether it's how far the
swingset can be from the parking lot
health and safety food safety you know
they are inspected by all kinds of
outside agencies and groups they're
licensed I mean it's not as if we have
this market already where the government
is an intervening so we need to work on
decentralization versus centralization
yeah
it is worth thinking about this is a
battle between centralization and
decentralization I mean the Obama
administration has really been a strong
on what did they call it the race to the
top initiative and the Department of
Education is pushing for national
standards so is this is this hurting
kids right so we have what we call now
the Common Core initiative and it's
interesting because the Obama
administration in some ways comes down
on both sides of the fence they have
taken a small portion of the federal
education budget which is several
billion dollars but still compared to
the hundred and fifty billion dollars
plus taking two billion dollars in
saying we'll divide that up among states
that have innovative proposals and we'll
call it race to the top you know while
we raise taxes and spending for
education overall far and above that so
and the Obama administration has been a
friend to charter schools they've
started several charter school
initiatives but on the on the flip side
you know President Obama would not stand
up for the Washington DC voucher program
while his own daughters were going to
one of the private schools that were
part of that DC scholarship program you
know he was never willing and that was
you know a few million dollars a teeny
tiny part of the overall that the
federal government spends on education
so you know overall the Obama
administration has still come down on
the side of centralization and inputs so
one of their big initiatives is that we
will have a common core set of
curriculum for every state and we'll
have basically a set of performance
tests that will measure that curriculum
for every state and so what's happened
with that is that states like
Massachusetts in actually California and
Indiana that have higher standards have
actually lowered their standards to meet
that bar so in California we have one of
the best math standards in the country
and all eighth graders take algebra
earlier than almost anywhere else in the
country and because of that we actually
have seen
huge gains in our math scores for
low-income and regular kids in
California so now we've changed that and
we're not going to do that anymore
because of common core standards and so
you have these tensions between more
centralization and less centralization
and the status quo at the federal level
the state level certainly buys into more
centralization and you know basically
the way the Obama administration have
gotten states to agree is I don't know
you remember the No Child Left Behind
which was you know George Bush's
education initiative it had certain
proficiency requirements so that every
by 2014 a hundred percent of kids were
supposed to be proficient in math and
reading besides the fact that whoever
designed that was not a mathematician
and that's statistically really
impossible the bottom line is now
without going through any kind of
legislation or congressional approval
but by an administrative waiver process
President Obama's administration has
said if you sign on to common core and
national tests we won't hold you
responsible for that old initiative so
they've never revisited the No Child
Left Behind legally it still stands but
they're basically giving every state a
waiver if you do XY and z we won't hold
you accountable for what was in that
previous law and we won't change the law
we'll just administratively do that so
just I mean wrapping up would you say
looking to the future in 2013 or are you
optimistic or are these other things
getting in the way and impeding school
choice I mean I think that school choice
is winning I'm very optimistic i like to
say that a lot and you know already this
year we've seen several large-scale
proposals for school choice so the
governor of ohio just said that he was
going so ohio has the Cleveland school
choice program and it has another
smaller school choice program for kids
stuck in failing schools the governor
has a proposal to make that into a
statewide school voucher program that
just came out this week
Tennessee you have Memphis is actually
replicating New Orleans and the recovery
school district and it seems to be a
very robust model where they want to
basically make every school a charter
school and make the money follow the
child from one school to the other I
think we've barely scratched the surface
with what technology and the digital
revolution is going to mean for you know
how things like Khan Academy and the
popularity of rocketship education where
they basically have saved on labor costs
where they have used computers and
technology for directed lessons for part
of the day and then they have teachers
just give lectures so they basically are
saving about forty percent of what it
costs to run a traditional school in
terms of teachers salaries you have
things like flipped classrooms where the
kids actually listen to a lecture on a
video at home at night instead of doing
homework and then they do all of their
work in the class with the teacher
supervising that work and so all these
interesting models that are just barely
starting and then the other thing things
like homeschooling millions more kids
can be homeschooled now because of
technology because it's less labor
intensive than it used to be and there's
all these kind of open-source resources
and then the other thing is even though
there's a lot of resistance in the
establishment I think one of the most
positive signs that things are changing
is that all kinds of districts are
changing their teacher contract to allow
for more autonomous schools getting rid
of tenure getting rid of seniority you
know you never would have heard of a
district voluntary negotiating for less
rules and less security without the
pressure and competition from charter
schools and other kinds of choice and so
you know there's a district in Arizona
called veil and they actually the whole
district has no textbooks it's all
online they use powerpoints and the
teachers collaborate and for five years
it's been the highest scoring
traditional school district in Arizona
and it's really blowing away the
competition and
public administrators wouldn't
experiment with things like that if they
weren't feeling market pressure from
everywhere so it's a great time to be a
parent it's a great time for kids
because I think more and more you have
just really a lot of choices available
great well I'm going to cut you off
there but thank you again for talking to
us Lisa snow thanks so much choice E and
thank you for watching reason TVs first
live stream interview so keep checking
reason calm and reason TV for upcoming
events and new videos for reason TV and
Tracy Oppenheimer